[Music]
I'm gonna tell you story at first it's
gonna sound ridiculous but the longer I
talk we have to find the keys the more
rational it's going to appear I can't
believe you found coffee sure Hank yeah
three how many times have we been here
how many times for me it's been an
eternity
[Music]
the invasion will fail we lose
everything
I die within 5 minutes of landing on man
each along with every other soldier
how did you do that come on come find me
when you wake up
you do know what's happening to me
what happened to you happened to me you
hijacked that power how do I control you
have to die every day keep coming here
and I'll train you
your legs broken no I'm good you better
start over soldier
your listen
they want to conquer the rest of the
world
unless you change them you're not
equipped for what's up
how many times every penny what are you
not telling me
that's gonna be dark in a few hours
curl up by the fire and open a bottle of
wine we should just reset whoa our world
is fire and blood
here they come again
[Music]
everybody's gone out of their mind
you're not the only hoarder max out here
everything hurts you want to get through
this
[Music]
do as I say
now pick up with you 10
[Music]
oh what a lovely day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you just starting your day or did you
just get off they call I go you know so
what is it you do what is your name baby
your name's baby Bab why baby this one
who say listen to the music all the time
maybe yeah mental mental meaning slow
was he slow no he had an accident when
he was a kid still has a hum in the drum
plays music to drown it out and that's
what makes him the best
[Music]
one more job when I'm done one more job
and we're straight I don't think I need
to give you this feature what happened
when you say no how I could break your
legs and tell everyone you loved because
you already know that diamond yeah
the moment you catch feelings is the
moment you catch a bullet and your uh
waitress girlfriend she's cute let's
keep it that way I want us to head west
and ever stop anyway I mean baby
[Music]
[Music]
one of these days baby
we gotta get blood on your hands face
the music baby we need to get out of
here I have to end this are we in bed
together now no the killer duel from
Halloween oh you mean Jason no baby you
tell me who does
yes
[Music]
you have no idea what's coming
mr. wit broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives an ex community is now in
effect you shouldn't be here
nice suit good to see you too I need
your help after this we are less than
either
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
would you help set the move for our new
guest
let us begin our services still
off-limits to me what do you need guns
lots of guns you think you can take John
wick you've got a nasty surprise coming
I've been looking forward to meeting you
for a long time
and so far you haven't disappointed
we can keep this up as long as you'd
like
but this only ends one way
[Music]
all of this for what because of a puppy
wasn't just a puppy
there's a storm coming
[Music]
you sound like you're looking forward to
it I'm adaptable what are you I'm
Gotham's reckoning
[Music]
did they kill him I'm not sure
why didn't you just tell me your
punishment must be more severe
[Music]
I don't know
how'd you run they you should be as
afraid of him as I am
I've heard enough members of the Wayne
family
you don't owe these people any
another warned me about getting into
cars with strange noise that's just no
good
huge IQ great performance of school but
you gave up drugs petty crimes never had
a job set you on a certain path
but you needn't stay on it who are you
the man who got your release
I've never met a tailor before I know
you ain't one come with me what do you
see I see a young man with potential
pull the hook honey on there oh yes very
nice
what is this the electric eel don't be
ridiculous it's a hand grenade shut up
that is sick we are an independent
international intelligence agency
operating at the highest level of
discretion the Kingsmen agents are the
new Knights you are about to embark from
the most dangerous job interview in the
world felt sorry for the boy did you he
will find this humiliating he's as much
Kingsman material at any of them we're
here to enhance your skills test you to
limits then you solve problems under
pressure like what to do when one of
your group has no parachute
interested
- maketh man I have trouble
understanding you people sometimes y'all
[Music]
what about him what makes him so special
put it back the God gave us many gifts
one day you'll know them all this is
where we keep them
it's beautiful who would wield it only
the fiercest among us even could and
that is not you Diana
you will train our harder than any
Amazon before her five times harder ten
times harder never let your guard down
you expect the battles will be fair
until she is better than even you but
she must never know the truth about what
she is
[Music]
what is this place who are you
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world right wherever you are you are in
more danger than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the world than I must welcome to Java
all of them be here yeah it's not for
everybody or maybe not
is there anything else you want to show
me
[Music]
[Music]
what
in akhira
in this world
[Music]
yep that's not gonna work please put the
sword down it doesn't go with the outfit
at all
cassie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man we lost I loved you when we
said no more surprises but I was really
hoping to pull off one last one
[Music]
we can do is our best and sometimes the
best we can do
start over
[Music]
I saw all these people die
I keep telling everybody they should
move on
someday us
[Music]
even if there's a small chance
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
[Music]
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
however it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
I like this one there's one thing you
should know about me I specialize in a
very specific type of security
subconscious security you're talking
about dreams
[Music]
mr. Cobb has a job offer he would like
to discuss with you our work placement
not exactly we create the world of the
dream we bring the subject into that
dream and they fill it with their
secrets then you break in and still it
well it's not strictly speaking leaving
it's called inception
and this last job
feel real while we're in them it's only
when we wake up that we realize
something was actually strange
the dual responsibilities they're not
prepared to this
treats classic
I have it under control
I need to see out of control
you mustn't be afraid to dream with a
bigger down it we gettin close
[Music]
you all know the drill and accept the
convoy watch out for cable he's in
trouble mover guy pump the hate breaks
Thanos
Halon cable get to but I can't do this
alone
back up we're gonna form a super duper
group it's time to get back on LinkedIn
meets bet in love
my name is chatter snark Domino I'm
lucky
luck isn't a superpower it's not very
cinematic yes it is let's meet in the
middle and say no it is alright it's
show time don't call it a comeback
[Music]
[Music]
you're no hero dressed up as a toy
so darks you sure you're not from the DC
Universe
bring it on one-eyed Willy
oh yeah your bullets they're really fast
last but not least Peter
any powered want to tell us about you I
don't have one I just saw the ad you're
in
[Music]
lovely what is you to Charles the world
is not the same as it was
[Music]
music
Oh God I heard myself today to see if I
still feel I focus on the pain
[Music]
the only thing that's real fishy they
need the stage like you of time very
much like you the feeling disappear she
needs our help you are small come on
someone has come along I am still right
here and you could
[Music]
to
I would find a way
Logan you still have time
[Music]
that's the coaster of 36 years old
violation today at bus stop 34 be what
hair products mostly thank you
welcome a little better
[Music]
cancer cells remove three undocumented
ships approaching Luc pair space shoot
them down we're still stealing cars no
since I got a normal life you will die
they can fix it I'm ELISA max I think I
can help get you up there
gave you a way out whoever has this has
the power to override their whole system
she's very sick max you to get her up
there you can't save everyone
when can I go
[Music]
activate Kruger
follow me stay close
[Music]
I am one of many specialized assassins
called bloopers we eliminate people from
the future time travel has not yet been
invented the 30 years from now and will
have been
criminal organizations in the future
needs someone God they zap it back to me
and I do the necessary
rule is never let your target escape
even if you target it's you he's on a
run on the pavements every second that
passes is bad
I'm gonna kill this guy your own self
wasn't my life kill this man I get it
back and I find you you know what's
gonna happen you done all this already I
know that you're still gonna kill Oh
have you heard of the Rainmaker
[Music]
you lost in the future
as executions
who's here now
none of this concerns me it's gonna
happen to you it happens to you it
doesn't have to happen to me
everything you've got
[Music]
ask yourself who would I sacrifice for
what's mine
we both know how this has to go down
can't let you walk away live
[Music]
my life now you had you Sorrenti
[Music]